Magic Mike taken that movie you would
have thought that was pretty risky right
what was risky about that that was a
no-brainer yeah but I don't know that I
would have known reading that script
that it would be that big a movie one
Steven soberg right he pitches it to one
him as a director right yes Steven
soberg hadn't called me before then I
been W I would love to work and he calls
this is a good day yeah so then he
pitches and he goes I got this guy he
runs the nightclub and he's a m stripper
and he and he if you play this really
he's really serious capitalist you play
it straight I think it could be really
funny and I'm like on my knees laughing
going okay I'm in just give me one one
line to take from this phone call just
to get my imagination going on the
character and he takes a long pause and
he goes well and the character's name's
Dallas he goes Dallas is he he is kind
of connected to the UFOs man and I'm
like that's it well you just took the
lid off thank you and after magic mik
that's when Dallas Buyers Club happens
right so now you're yes now I am I have
a hold of of the script Dallas Buyers
Club for a while but no one's going to
finance and make it with me why again no
we still got some we've still got some
hangover from wait a minute I'm not sure
that this is the right guy is is it
gonna be worth it can he do it blah blah
blah right I see a film called crazy
which I loved with John Mark fet we meet
here in New York he loves the script
wants to do it I want to do it um and he
uh there we were we were off but then
even that we willed that picture into
happening we were I was saying and he
was saying we're making it in October
when we didn't have any money to make it
we were talking out of our ass we were
bullshitting but the thing is we didn't
Flinch so every other other scripts
would come in this is for October and
I'd tell my agent why you sh me another
script we're doing Dallas spers club and
people were behind the scenes were going
you're not really doing it there's no
financing we're like yes we are cuz no
one belied it could be a financial
success yes we are yes we are and so I
get a call eight days before we go to
shoot dpes Club from Jean Mark and he
says the director he goes Matthew I I I
I had needed to have a a minimum of $7.5
million doar to make this movie and all
of a sudden I found out to have less
than five I don't know how I can make
this
movie but if you will be there on day
one I I will show up as well eight days
before that is crazy we show up in eight
days in that eight days he scrapped the
grip Department which for those of you
who don't know it's lighting the only
light on the entire was a headlight from
the car that pulled me up really yeah
tell me about this guy Jared Leto do we
enjoy working with him we like him let's
great but now
is he he's one of those guys got to be
in character right I mean he's like this
what's great about this is what you like
are you one of those guys when you're on
a set do you have to be in character the
whole time I would rather be right Leto
and I didn't meet until the after the
final scene of the movie you're kidding
no that's when all first time we
finished into rap and I turn around I go
Leto how's it going he goes it's going
all right MCC that was Fun's the band he
he he stole stuff from me just as rayon
would steal from me he never called
you uh MCC absolutely not he stayed in
character the whole time and you never
got to meet him every time he didn't
meet me when you're at the craft service
table and he's his character and you're
your character you mean there's no he's
Ray on I'm probably punching him in the
arm saying back off wow you know I mean
what and it that's fun that's not a pain
in the ass most actors think that's
cuckoo no it's not cuckoo if it's constr
look if it all actors have their
different things they do if it's
constructive to doing the best way work
hey man pour fire on the on pour gas on
the fire let's go do it now if you have
these things you do that are not
constructive if that means oh you're not
coming out of the trailer for five hours
to work well that's right but
do what you go for it we're play and
make believe let's make them
believe